digamos que tengo la función f x igual a
8 veces el logaritmo natural de x menos
equis cuadrada y por supuesto esta
función la vamos a definir en un dominio
y el dominio va a ser el intervalo
cerrado 1,4 y cuando hablamos del
intervalo cerrado estamos pensando por
supuesto en que tanto el punto 1 como el
punto 4 están incluidos en el dominio de
la función muy bien entonces la pregunta
que te hago y que espero puedas hacer
una pausa y tratar de resolverlo por tu
cuenta es encontrar cuál es el valor
máximo absoluto el valor máximo absoluto
de nuestra función f
muy bien esta es la pregunta te invito a
que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolverlo
ok entonces espero ya hayas hecho una
pausa y al menos intentado dar una
respuesta del problema vamos a ver qué
pasa vamos a utilizar el teorema del
valor extremo que es lo que nos dice el
teorema del valor extremo digamos que
tengo yo un intervalo cerrado muy bien
tenemos aquí un intervalo cerrado y el
teorema del valor extremo nos dice que
siempre que tengamos una función
continua en un intervalo cerrado
entonces podremos encontrar tanto el
máximo absoluto de efe como el valor
mínimo absoluto de f por ejemplo y de
hecho tenemos varias varios escenarios o
varias varias posibilidades en que esto
puede ocurrir por ejemplo si aquí
estamos definiendo nuestra función
podríamos tener algo así que el valor
extremo o el valor máximo de la función
se encuentra en alguno de los extremos
del intervalo que por ejemplo puede que
ocurra algo así
verdad y entonces el máximo se encuentra
en uno de los extremos puede ocurrir
otra situación que el valor máximo se
encuentre al inicio del intervalo como
más o menos de esta forma puede ocurrir
o bien también puede ocurrir que no esté
bien
más bien en los extremos del intervalo
sino que ande por en medio en cuyo caso
sí es bastante bien comportará la
función aquí tendremos que la pendiente
de 0 en donde está el máximo o bien
podríamos tener una cuarta situación en
donde tengamos el máximo de esta forma
muy bien en cuyo caso la derivada no
está definida entonces en este tipo de
situaciones por ejemplo en este a este
valor layout le llamamos el punto
crítico verdad el punto crítico es aquel
en donde la derivada hacia nula este es
el punto crítico muy bien entonces vamos
a ver dónde están los extremos vamos a
evaluar más bien la función en los
extremos del del intervalo y luego
calcularemos la derivada para encontrar
valores críticos o bien donde no está
definida la función ok y luego vamos a
comparar cuánto vale la función en cada
uno de ellos entonces quien es la
derivada de nuestra función f
entonces tendremos que derivar 8 por el
logaritmo natural de x la derivada es 8
entre x menos la derivada de x cuadrada
que es 2x y si yo quiero hallar puntos
críticos tengo que ver cuando esto es
igual a 0 entonces podemos sumar 2x de
ambos lados y tenemos 8 / x es igual a
2x
si ahora multiplicamos de ambos lados
por x tendremos que 8 es 2x cuadrada si
dividimos de ambos lados entre 2
tendremos que 4 es x cuadrada y si ahora
sacamos una raíz cuadrada tendremos que
x es más o menos 2 muy bien entonces
tenemos estos dos puntos críticos sin
embargo hay que recordar lo siguiente la
función está definida en el intervalo
1,4 así que menos 2 no tiene sentido
porque no está en este en este intervalo
así que el único punto crítico que
tenemos es
es igual a 2 muy bien ahora también
podríamos preguntarnos donde no está
definida la derivada y vemos que sólo
hay un punto en donde no está definida
verdad aquí tenemos 8 / x así que no
estaría de perdón definida cuando x es
igual a 0 sin embargo en x igual a 0 o
más bien el punto igual a 0 no está en
nuestro dominio así que también la
derivada está definida en todos lados
así que nuestros candidatos para valores
máximos absolutos son efe de 1 que es
evaluar en un extremo y esto sería ocho
veces logaritmo natural de uno menos uno
al cuadrado también podríamos tener efe
de cuatro que es evaluar en el otro
extremo y tendríamos ocho veces
logaritmo natural de 4 menos 4 al
cuadrado o bien
efe de 2 que es nuestro punto crítico y
esto sería ocho veces logaritmo natural
de dos menos dos al cuadrado podríamos
utilizar una calculadora y ver cuál de
éstos es más grande pero vamos a tratar
de hacerlo intuitiva
o al menos con un buen análisis notemos
que el logaritmo natural de 1 vale 0 así
que esto de aquí vale 0 y sólo nos queda
menos 1 al cuadrado que es menos 1 ahora
bien
efe de 4 cuánto es tenemos ocho veces el
logaritmo natural de 4 menos 4 al
cuadrado
ok entonces no sé podríamos tratar de
ver por ejemplo el 4 es mayor que el
número e y menor que al cuadrado verdad
recordemos que es como 2.71 me parece
algo así ok
sí sí sí ya recordé bien y él es 2.718
más o menos entonces 4 está por abajo de
cuadrada quiere decir que el logaritmo
natural de 4 está entre el logaritmo
natural de e y el logaritmo natural de
cuadrada que es decir el logaritmo
natural de 4 está entre 1 y 2 muy bien y
esto nos dice que ocho veces el
logaritmo natural de 4 está entre 8 y 16
pero si después restamos 16 eso quiere
decir que estamos entre menos 8 y 0
y bueno no tenemos forma de saber bien
cómo es con respecto a efe de uno pero
lo que sí sabemos es que éste es
negativo y éste es negativo
ahora bien efe de dos cuánto es
veamos que 2 es más grande que la raíz
cuadrada de quiere decir que el
logaritmo natural de 2 es más grande que
un medio y 8 por un medio es más o bueno
más bien 8 por el logaritmo natural de 2
es mayor que 8 por un medio que es 4 y
si le restamos 4 quiere decir que esto
es más grande que 0 quiere decir que
esto de aquí es positivo y por lo cual
yo le voy a elegir este como mi valor
máximo de la función muy bien entonces
este es el valor máximo de la función y
se alcanza en el punto crítico en que es
que es 2 ahora nada más vamos a
comprobarlo con la calculadora por
ejemplo si calculamos el logaritmo
natural de 4 es y luego lo multiplicamos
por 8 y luego le restamos 16 tenemos que
esto es menos menos 5 más o menos es
como menos 5 y esto era positivo verdad
porque tenemos él
ritmo natural de dos que si lo
multiplicamos por ocho nos da 5.55 más o
menos y si le restamos cuatro obtenemos
1.55 más o menos que en efecto es
positivo y este es nuestro valor máximo
lo lo más interesante es que antes lo
pudimos resolver sin utilizar la
calculadora